hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
a property investor and in this video
I'm gonna be giving you three ways how
you can buy a hay chamo property using
none of your own manager what is a HMO
HMO is a house of multiple occupancy
it's probably the most profitable way of
renting out property on a residential
basis instead of renting out a house to
a family or to a single person you went
out on a room-by-room basis that's what
it's called hey chair house of multiple
occupancy first question is how much
money do you typically need when buying
a chomo property so maybe you want to do
it with no money at all that's fine
we'll get there but firstly how much do
you normally need well I normally buy my
HMOs between a hundred and 150 thousand
pounds that would just be for a four-bed
HMO now for a four-bit HMO you do not
need a license you don't need to get
registered with the council however I
would still suggest getting fire doors
and doing it properly but you want to
get a license so it does give you a
little bit more freedom so 100 to 150
thousand pounds what should deposit
going to be 25 percent that's going to
be somewhere between around about 25 35
40 thousand pounds the deposit on top of
that you can activate stamp due today on
top of that you're gonna have to pay for
the fire doors and the smoke alarms and
also depending on if you buy or lease
the furniture you might have some costs
there as well so on average this is
going to be broadly speaking you might
need around about 40,000 pounds forty
five thousand pounds all in to buy a hey
chair mo now if you've got forty
thousand pounds that's a smart thing to
do because the return is great because
you're gonna rent it out room by room
how much the rooms rent out for maybe
about 350 400 pounds per room you're
gonna have to pay bills council tax your
mortgage payments on average a HMO
property will leave you with a profit of
around about somewhere between six and
ten hundred pounds a month the great
thing about HMOs is you don't need many
of those to retire if you're getting
eight hundred pound profit clean profit
in your back pocket per month for a HMO
you just need what four or five of those
- making a good few thousand pounds a
month and you are financially free
that's why so many people want to buy
HMOs problem is people don't have
lots of deposits 40 grand here 40 gram
they're kicking about to go ahead and
buy these hate em O's if you have got
the money what do you do well there's
three really easy ways to buy a Hayti mo
of no money
the first way is to just joint venture
just joint venture or borrow the money
if you know how to you take 40,000
pounds put it down and make seven eight
hundred pounds profit a month on that
money but you haven't got the forty
thousand pounds just borrow it pay a
small return on investment and then keep
the difference and then have a free
house it's just this is not rocket
scientist you know and people say that's
risky it's only risky if you don't know
what you're doing if you know what
you're doing so what all which people do
Robert Kiyosaki talks about this having
infinite return Grant Cardone
these are all people that I've sat with
chatted with have coffee with Grant
Cardone he borrows people's money then
invested it give us a fixed return keeps
the rest and has free houses so that
would be the first way now of course
you've got to know what you're doing if
you're going to borrow people's money or
even if you're gonna borrow the bank's
money you need to know what you're doing
another option which is still going to
count those three but this is still
number one is joint venture if you know
someone who's got the money but hasn't
got the know-how that you have when it
comes to HMOs or maybe they live in an
area where HMOs don't work and they
think that you have to be close by
because they they don't understand or
maybe they think that HMOs are good but
they're a lot of work and they don't
want to put the work in you could say
hey investor I know you like the idea of
the cash flow of HMOs but you don't know
exactly where to buy it and this this
the hassle how about this i as a HMO
expert will buy the HMO
I will manage it I'll do everything I'll
liaise with the carpenters to come up at
the fire doors in or everything you put
the money in and we'll go 50/50 on any
profits how's that sound you might not
be getting seven hundred pan a month
you're only getting 350 but you put no
money in just do that twice it's as if
you did it with your own money other
people's money banks money race finance
joint venture that's just one way the
second way to buy HMOs using non of your
own money if you haven't got unlimited
deposits buy a house that needs a lot of
work doing to it and instead of just
refurbishing it into a lovely family
home assuming of course it's in the
right area to be a potential HMO then
when you restore it restore it to a HMO
you buy a house maybe a two three bed
horrible
really ugly but in a good location I was
saying buy the worst house in the best
street
once you've restored it into a HMO then
you refinance it and if you do it right
you can pull back all of your money out
Lia and Cheryl Miller have been doing
this successfully in Telford I've done
this many of us students do this it's
called buy refurbish refinance rent and
I know you've probably seen people do
this with little tiny houses and invite
them out for five hundred and fifty
pounds a month you can do that you can
also do it really successfully hmo's
great thing about doing the HMOs you can
turn the rooms into little beds it's I'd
recommend speaking to a value out and
the lender before you do this don't do
it off this YouTube video you can get a
HMO and then you can value it based off
the commercial value if it's the right
kind HMO so you can buy ugly residential
house restore it make it beautiful
put it room by room studio apartments
however you want to do it and then get a
new value based off of the commercial
value and the commercial value is a case
of how much is it going to rent for
value it hire and then pull out all of
the money that you first put in and
that's called recycling your cash and
this is so easy to do when you have the
right knowledge this is easy if you've
got a little bit of money maybe you've
got 40 50 60 thousand pounds and you
don't want to just go ahead and buy one
HMO and then what what's next instead
you can recycle it you haven't got the
money you can do a combination of one
and two so you can borrow someone else's
money or joint venture with someone else
HMO restore it refinance it and then do
it again and again and again and again
so you can do a combination of one
answer if you do number two and you're
going to add value and then we finance
it the way to do is to get a bridging
loan so you're going to put down a
little bit of deposit to buy the house
which you want to borrow someone's money
or you might have then get a short-term
bridging loan for the rest of the
balance of the purchase price you can
also get a hundred percent refurb
financed so you can get another bridging
loan to pay for the refurb and then get
a whole new loan which will be a
mortgage commercial mortgage hmm
mortgage bites let mortgage whatever
depending on the house and then that
pays off the others and pays you back
for the deposit that you put down in the
first place it's just genius so that's
the second way of buying a HMO with no
money or someone else's money and keep
recycling getting going on and on if you
don't understand that you've got
questions on that comment below and
maybe I need to do a deep
video about this number three this is
how it made most of my wealth improper
today went to rent so rental rate is if
you saw if you find a HMO or property
it's got the potential to be a HMO but
it's not being around as an HMO and you
say to the landlord hey I know you
looking to rent this house out you're
asking for six hundred pound a month I
think you could run it as a HMO and get
a sixteen hundred pound a month why
don't you do that and then Alan says
well because I can't be bothered I don't
want the hassle and then you say to him
or listen I understand that but I'm
happy to have that I'll so how about you
want six hundred I'll give you six
hundred and I'll pay for all the
maintenance I'll give you a guaranteed
six hundred pound for five years and
then all went out as a HMO now from his
point of view you're giving him what he
wants
plus you're paying for any maintenance
issues you're giving him a guaranteed
event so he has no voids from your point
of view you're giving him six hundred
but then you're renting it as a hey
tomorrow and you're keeping all the
profit you're keeping all the difference
and you don't own it which is cool
that's a rental rent so what I do is I
do that with a landlord but then I put I
set an agreed price to buy the property
but down the line so let's say you've
got a landlord who's selling the house I
was trying to rent it and he's a tired
hmm landlord or he's a tired landlord
and if the house has potential to be
hate him out but he doesn't know I
understand so you say look I'll buy it
off you for you set the price now but in
five years time or seven years time then
you pay a monthly rent you keep all the
cash flow each month the difference with
that cash flow what do you do you go to
Nando's with the money you're going
holidayed you buy a new car no any
profit that you make you put it aside
and then in five years what do you use
it for you use it to buy the house which
means that the deal is paid for itself
oh and guess what cherry on the cake in
five years what happens to properties
did that properties over time do they go
up or down and the answer is of course
up so in five years
the properties probably gone up in value
even if it hasn't you can still buy it
but if it's gone up you buy it for the
price that you agreed then so you use
all that income to buy the house you've
also got a bargain the house has gone up
in value you can potentially then we
finance it and use the deposit again to
buy another one
this is how it snowballs when you know
the skills have been able to buy
properties we've known of your own man
and when you do HMOs geez it's good
because you don't need many HMOs to
replace you're an average income which
means that you can be financially free
when you become financially free what do
you do you go buy more and you keep
snowballing it until you become super
wealthy why do you want to become super
wealthy for me it's about a mission it's
about helping people it's about leaving
a difference in the world what the
reason I do these YouTube videos is
because I'm on a mission I want to leave
the world a better place than I found it
and I want to be remembered for
something bigger than myself
so I'd love to help as many people as
possible if you want to help me then
just smash the subscribe button drop a
comment below because if your success is
my oxygen and see in the comments it
really really gives me a lot of
satisfaction so thank you so much I hope
you enjoyed the video and I'll see you
next time
[Music]